what's up you guys big lotto check your
girl out on the bootleg care podcast
boulet cab show special guest
the legend in the making
special special guest lotto welcome hey
hey first of all congratulations thank
you i saw you posted your 2022 goals and
you've already knocked one off in
january and that's being top 10. they
were not over yet i know i said oh top
40 on billboard right that i had to post
that because i was like
i wrote this goal list for like the year
not the
three weeks into the year yeah i mean
that's a big accomplishment um you've
had such a long journey in this music
industry
um some people are just finding out who
you are like there's like you know i
i show people your la leakers freestyle
all the time or i'm like no lotto's hard
like but you've been around for so long
just grinding as an up-and-coming artist
like
to get that first top 40 records got to
feel amazing man what this stuff like
like you said i've been rapping for a
long long time so this stuff like
eight-year-old me dreamed up i don't
take nothing for granted like
i love my life
so on your goals list you had a lot of
stuff blurred out can you can you give
us one of the blurred goals
um one of them
was obviously
that feature you know
that feature that feature
if you know you know i can't even
elaborate because you know you're not
even supposed to talk about stuff like
this you're supposed to just let it
manifest you can't like can i take a
guess
beyonce
i don't know i'm not gonna confirm with
d9 beyonce future would be kind of hot
super fire
yeah
i really feel like
i would like to see i don't know why
this this is random because maybe
musically you guys have different styles
but each of you can rap
at a very elite level
lauren hill just was on naz's album oh
[ __ ] you know what my daddy loved lauren
my daddy loved lauren we met um jerry
wonder and i guess he like produced for
them no disrespect but you know i don't
this past my generation i just know i
grew up and my daddy would like put me
down with all this stuff and i'd be like
okay no didn't know that no didn't know
they know this so i know the names and
you know a little bit of their catalogs
and i was like
my name was like [ __ ] you know the [ __ ]
i'm like yeah yeah
so you did so so your dad had to put you
on the lauren [ __ ] and the fuji's and
the score and all that yeah yes wow um
jerry like produced like a major like he
produced something i can't remember but
i made him cool as [ __ ] humble as hell
like
yeah you're pop like was he like a huge
music head did he have like a lot of
influence just kind of yeah like he um
it was more like not just overall music
just like more like hip-hop you know
everything else like i i learned like
the r b [ __ ] from my grandma
my mama so your dad was putting you up
on the rap [ __ ] yeah
and then he didn't really [ __ ] with too
many females but like the ones that i
know i know
from him like that [ __ ] when he [ __ ]
with a [ __ ] like he loved left eye he
loved lauren like you know what i'm
saying um who else you know
kim like we're his favorite like uh just
rappers in general like what was the
[ __ ] that you were like jumping in the
car with your dad and it was i know his
favorite song ever is like something
bone thugs phone thugs and harmony yeah
something probably crossroads something
like that
um ice cube
today was a good day or a good day
we need to move your dad to l.a because
both of those artists perform at some
festival in ontario california once
every 90 days there's like a toyota
center west coast fest going on and he's
an ice cube oh yeah so he like he from
ohio though but he like loved like west
coast like well ohio bone's from ohio so
that makes sense yeah shout out and he
do love him some bone child but he like
he go crazy for an nwa
hug like yeah so i grew up on it i still
my my parents were like into like def
leopard and like yeah
no i got you know
my momma's side and my daddy's side so i
got like a little bit of everything i'm
not too um
familiar with everything yeah cause
you're you're mixed right so your mom
what was she listening to
see my mama was more like all over the
place like she loved
like r b old school r b but like she
grew up on like country music like that
side like her mom and them they like
country music like when i go out there
for like and during the summer and stuff
it'd be like country yeah
you know it's funny because like i just
started watching this show called
yellowstone have you heard of the show
it's with kevin costner it's about this
ranch in montana some gangster [ __ ]
it's like power but with cowboys what is
gangsta about a rancher no there's some
gangster-ass [ __ ] this these
[ __ ] cowboys would be killing
people it's [ __ ] wild but it may be
like be like dang i need to start
listening to country because this [ __ ]
for you i feel like country is kind of
like rap music but just for rednecks no
i think i think it's it's with all the
music genres like we be talking about
the same [ __ ] it's just like our beats
are different our flows are different
you know what i'm saying we all talking
about [ __ ] getting money and all type
of [ __ ]
we just saying it differently 100 100
um if you had to like you know give me
like your top three influences just as a
rapper that you you know because you
like i said you've been doing this a
long time like who was who was like very
influential to you and your style
top three i'm gonna say for sure nicky
cause you know i grew up like i was
saying like my dad taught me about all
these females that came before me but
it's like it's different when somebody
come out during your generation because
they feel like yeah she touched me yeah
she's the goat yeah like definitely
heavy influence i used to budge uh
nikki um gucci gucci always been my
favorite rapper like that slow southern
aesthetic like
and then you know i grew up around that
lifestyle so it was like
i i appealed to that
then i would say
i'm stuck between
i'd probably say t.i t.i tia you see
ti's doing stand-up comedy now huh he
was on stage
the comedy is clubbing it looks like he
give me that yeah give me that shout out
to you
you know gucci uh you know gucci to me
is the greatest a r in hip hop history
yeah i think he's got the best ear we've
ever seen no yeah he's gonna find him an
artist that nobody heard of and they're
gonna blow he don't blow yeah and like
if you even just think of the people
he's put his arm around early like the
egos or even like nikki yeah nikki
exactly like what was it like to have
him put his arm around you and have him
on one of your first records that really
commercial that [ __ ] was solid cause
gucci ain't just gonna stamp no [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying like you can't
just
pay gucci to do a feature and he just
gonna do it cause you paying him type
[ __ ] he gotta actually [ __ ] with you you
know what i'm saying so when they was
like i actually know a case in which he
did take some money from a korean pop
band it was a nice bag yeah yeah shout
out to him
but anyway it was it was a night
it was a it was a great bag so anyway
it depends what kind of money we talk
about what i'm saying
but no like they was like no he [ __ ]
with you like he he gonna pull up to the
video he's gone like whatever and he was
just humble as hell and then that's big
for atlanta like you talking about [ __ ]
like being from atlanta
gucci is legendary period like i feel
like he is kind of the mountain the
mount rushmore in atlanta like we could
talk about gz and ti
but i just feel like in atlanta
is gucci and then it's everyone else
respectively yeah now maybe nationally
when we think of atlanta you put jeezy
up there i just think in atlanta
gucci is the uh he is the uh
he is that he's the one he's him duncan
he's him yeah
i like that yeah for sure for sure um so
with this record
big energy yeah
this is a record that as soon as i heard
it i said okay she finally got her
crossover record this is it this is this
is your moment like i was like okay this
[ __ ] is like a lady i know what it's
gonna do this is a layup the sample
everything about it was just great like
um
it you know i was talking to lori
earlier and she was like it's just such
an easy song to work like if you
don't play this song you're a [ __ ]
hater yeah did you know that right away
as soon as you cut the record like that
it had that potential you know what i
did but i would only say i did because
i'm so hard on myself
i'm so hard on myself the only reason
why i feel like i knew that is because
first of all i was working on this song
for like a week like every day going to
the studio working on the same song
eight hours
but every time when i went back home
went to the hotel
i was like humming that [ __ ] so i'm like
this [ __ ] means something this [ __ ]
means something because i'll get
frustrated and then leave a song
you know then come back to a couple
months later well i did like that song
but that one i did not leave it alone
because i'm like i keep humming this
[ __ ] for a reason you know
so
yeah um have you ever had a guy have big
thick energy and end up not
his energy not necessarily lining up
with his actual physical uh
situation you know i ain't gonna lie i
i've been blessed in that department um
i feel for my sisters i read y'all
stories on twitter and [ __ ] like i
thought he had big big dick energy and
then we went to his crib and then [ __ ]
kind of was a little disappointing and i
asked like a question like that on
twitter i was like you know like have
you ever been
in a situation where it wasn't big dick
energy and the stories i was reading
child i'm like
baby i'm blessed
i'm blessed
like i feel like bless
like what like what is the energy you
think because i know i know guys with
little dick energy usually they have
they have like really big trucks or like
um it's just like do too much like it
don't even got to be like a material
thing or like what you own it's just
like a more of a like
personal like
like it's a charisma big big dick energy
is the charisma or uh
personality it's just like how you walk
how you talk it's not even like oh i got
a chain
oh i got a ferrari right like how you
carry yourself nine times out of ten
they gotta they gotta compensate you
know
i can't deal with that little medicine
drone [ __ ] yeah no well you've been
blessed yeah i'm very blessed shout out
to you
um is there going to be a remix for this
record because it feels like the kind of
record there should be like a maybe a
dozier cat feature on the remix you guys
are all the same labels
again bring dojo
no we're definitely working on a remix
we're definitely working on rooms it's
just this song is like it's open so many
doors for me so i'm like and i'm already
just hands-on with my career like right
i irritate everybody everybody gets
someone i know i get on everybody's name
they don't wanna know too but i know i
get on everybody now so you know i'm
just like being very particular about it
it's like yeah i'm not just gonna
just let anybody i could hear dogia cat
on this though i can too have you guys
talked there been a little chat
maybe some sort of music
in general i don't want to say yes or no
i feel like it'd be such an easy play
you guys are the same record label yeah
let's just put it in the air dojo cat on
the big energy remix i like the way that
sounds
i like the way it sounds i haven't even
made like a for sure decision on who i
want i'm not sure you could put a man on
there but they telling me like
could you put a man on the on the big
dick energy remix i'm not sure you could
because cause you would some of my
options are but you would have to
wouldn't you have to kind of like be
like listen man
you can't have no schmedium dick down
there if you're gonna be on the remix
[Music]
well who finna find out i don't know
maybe you you get only fans girl to test
it out
like asa i'm thinking about him for the
um i saw that he was liking your picks
i'm curious how was it yeah
no i think i think it would be cool to
hear a boy perspective too though that's
fair that's fair that's fair what what
would you be saying have to be a girl
what would the girl
if a guy made a remix to your record and
but he put the male perspective on it
yeah what would it what would it be what
would be like instead of it would it be
like clean
no i feel like
they expecting it to be clean because
it's like
big radio records no i mean like would
it be like clean [ __ ] energy or would
it be like what would he say what would
be the male perspective yes
[Music]
big dick energy is
because it can be big [ __ ] energy
because that's not a trap
that sounds like you got a bodybuilder a
bodybuilder
growth hormones um
yeah probably like clean like like good
a balanced ph energy balanced ph energy
i like the balanced ph energy i like
that
um you know i feel like a lot of people
have used the pandemic as an excuse to
be lazy or why they ain't popping or why
they're broke
we know a lot of [ __ ] rappers
who's struggling right i feel like you
really
just glue up on a whole nother level
career-wise in the last two years yeah
like what i was gonna say what like what
was your mind state going through
because i really put that pressure on
myself though like nobody knew this but
i had signed in december
the years depending on 2019 20
no 2020. because you signed during the
pandemic no no 2019. so you've started
yeah before the pandemic yeah so it's
been two and a half years
oh two years and a couple months our
life's just flying it sure is anyways
2019 december 2019 i signed nobody knew
because we was like you know trying to
just
have a game plan before i just of course
just
announcing [ __ ] and [ __ ] so
i was already signed december we didn't
announce it till like march and then the
pandemic like hit hit in like april
yeah it was like it hit in march low-key
yeah like it was like
when i announced it like i remember like
talks of that like that same week type
[ __ ] type [ __ ] like or two weeks later
type [ __ ] like oh
it's gonna be this
like shut down like i remember being
like
hmm
i just signed this deal we got this
whole we got [ __ ] games yeah we gotta
we got stuff we gotta do yeah so what do
you mean shut down i was just like nah
hell and i've been waiting all my life
for this [ __ ] major record deal yeah
yeah stop now so it doesn't hurt too
atlanta really never closed atlanta was
lit
we was in atlanta in january last year
and i was it was like it was like being
in a different world because we live
here and over here is [ __ ] up like you
can't go nowhere you got to pull up
we were in atlanta and i was like jesus
christ
i ain't gonna say that's a good thing
it's a bad thing it's just a different
thing i ain't mad at it
it's kind of like you know i think a lot
of those cities kind of blew up low-key
like a lot i know a lot of people who
were just going to atlanta to party
going to miami to party because they
couldn't party here yeah or going to
arizona even like scottsdale that [ __ ]
just a sensitive subject have you caught
the rona yet i did have corona yeah i
did i feel like everyone's going to
catch it right the end of november
early december was it a uh mild case
yeah maz was like the new variant
whatever that's like omicron the only
yeah the omarion [ __ ] the omarion yo
marion's nothing right it's like it's
like a cup of coffee only like um
i only tested positive for like three
days well
i think no no i tested positive for
like a week whatever but
the like contagious stage is only like
three days and it just really feel like
a cold like i had the old school where i
couldn't smell oh yeah hell nah so i'm
not it's funny because i woke up one
morning and my wife was cooking
breakfast
and i was like
you're cooking
yeah i can't smell nuts
and i have like a little small pot about
taste i i could still taste but it was
it was like 70 percent like normal but
so i have like a little pomeranian like
a little dog right
and he shat on the grass outside
and i said this is the real test
i got on my knees i took a sniff of his
[ __ ] and i didn't smell nothing i said
well looks like i'm [ __ ] well i mean
you know what i'm saying that could be a
good thing though there's nothing good
out of not being able to taste there's
nothing yet so i i do have a friend
who allegedly can't smell his name cj
complex
allegedly i say because allegedly
he says because he can't smell
he says that he's never had to worry
about
woman odors in his life and i while i do
understand that could be a positive to
me it's a serious negative
because you have no idea what you're
signing up for like you wouldn't like
you would know like if something was
crazy you'd be like i gotta
rethink this but for him he's just and
he can't taste either so he's just kind
of had coronavirus his whole life
allegedly
uh
wait you saying like he was born like
this hey some [ __ ] happen i don't even
know i don't even know oh so this don't
have nothing to do he can't taste he
can't smell like for since i've known
him it's been like since oh wait
i wouldn't say that like that's a good
thing to not be able to smell i agree
but he acts like it's a good thing man
you know i'm like bro it's not a good
thing
yeah no it's not a good thing yikes
tasting would be the worst though
what do you like to eat
like
no i don't you your mind went there i
see where it went i just meant i just
meant
i was coming from a fat guy perspective
yeah talking about actual food see i'm
talking about if he can't taste
so that's another thing
if he goes down there and it's and it's
sour you won't even know i don't know
it could be bad
and if you're the chick like let's say
he's in a relationship with a girl yeah
she low-key could be like man i ain't
even [ __ ] showering he's going to eat
my [ __ ] anyway what's the matter
this ain't good it's not a balanced ph
energy not balanced ph energy at all but
in general what you live in atlanta
which is uh one of the best food cities
um
i love going to atlanta and eating as a
matter of fact some of the best cuisine
is in strip clubs
what is your favorite [ __ ] to eat like
what do you enjoy eating the most 10
peas lemon pepper wick
10 piece lemon pepper what yep which
strip club though
because
magic city's flame magic
i ain't gonna say win so i'm not
[ __ ] on no chef
but one time like kind of recent
let's say within like a year
um
that [ __ ] was not as good as it usually
is i heard blue killer mike always tells
me blue flame yeah no everybody say blue
flame
um
yeah that's really like if you're going
for like food but you know that's more
of like that ain't the most touristy
[ __ ]
are you um
are you beneath at this point eating
waffle house at 4am hell [ __ ] no
i eat wiper house faithfully
it's gotta be like old faithful right
it's like you know what it is like you
know what you're getting it's always
open
and it's good [ __ ] food there might
be a world star fight in the lobby yeah
the chef might you're cool
yo waffle has a y i feel like at least
once a month there's like a viral
youtube video about waffle house like
it's like a house is legendary pensacola
florida waffle house chef shoots patron
over meth deal
it goes down and walk out like i didn't
pay i didn't pay the [ __ ] chef like
they be like acting like they fake
clothes and [ __ ] like when they get too
busy like around like 3 a.m when
everybody coming out of the club so
they'll pull up and they'll be like now
we ain't taking orders i give 300.
you're paying 300
god bless you
and they'll take it and they'll give you
their mixtape yeah yeah last time i went
to atlanta i swear to god i might be
lying i went to atlanta the chef
recognized me he gave me my food and
passed me his mixtape
i was like you know what welcome to
atlanta i'm gonna pop that in bro
i'm gonna see what you got i would see
what it sounded like it'd always be
weird for me when they when they do that
to me because i'd be like [ __ ] i'm
trying to make it the [ __ ] yeah i'm
still on my [ __ ] like i excited you
right now brother like what you want me
to do i'm worried about my [ __ ] hey look
yeah what i'm going to do you want me to
pass this [ __ ] to somebody
yeah yeah but i just be like yeah you
know good luck
what's up y'all got to interrupt the
bootleg cab podcast we have a brand new
sponsor
and i love this sponsor i've been giving
them my money for a long time it's about
time they gave some back my bookie yes
that's right
if you are a gambler if you're not a
gambler let me tell you my bookie is the
best place to go all right super bowl
season is here super bowl 56 is right
here and trust me my boogies double
deposit bonus is something you don't
want to miss if you sign up at my
booking now use the promo code bootleg
that's b-o-o-t-l-e-g
to have your first deposit matched
instantly
up to a thousand dollars so if you put a
thousand in they'll match your thousand
dollars and you get in on all the action
for super bowl 56 i mean seriously
joe burrow versus matthew stafford the
rams are playing the super bowl at home
in la what does that even mean because
none of these home games i've been to
them
it's a lot of out outdoor fans coming in
the 49ers but took that place over twice
in the last month we'll see how the
bengals fans show up all right this is
the most important game of the year it's
the biggest game of the year and you can
get paid by watching it my book is
giving you everything you need to do it
with that double your money you can
double your winnings and the best
starting point for the big game is these
super bowl prop bets they're fun
anybody can do these right
hey mom what color do you think the
gatorade is going to be to get spilled
at the end of the game hey what about
that toy the coin flip is it heads or is
it tails whatever it is is matthew
stafford going to throw a stupid ass
interception probably
probably
is joe mixon going to score a touchdown
i like it i don't know get in on that
prop back action and uh listen even if
you don't pick on who's gonna win you
you could be a winner all right uh it's
it's a great look the prop bets are the
most fun for the super bowl so don't
miss out head to my bookie double your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
by using the promo code bootleg
place your bets get ready for the
unmatched excitement for that super bowl
that is a thousand dollars in free money
that they will match so you deposit a
thousand they match a thousand bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
let's get back to the podcast it's
pretty dope like like the last few years
i've just noticed how
atlanta is fully behind you like you are
like they take pride in you they show up
they see me grow up though yeah and so
you know we always hear about like i
feel like
90 of
well first of all culture hip-hop music
all of this has been in atlanta's for
the last 20 years oh yeah for sure since
like 2000 it's been a very long time you
guys have had the
the rains
but um
we always hear about like how important
it is if you're coming out of atlanta
to and it's very heavily saturated
market with artists because a lot of
people moved there too to try to make it
in the rap game what were the things you
had to make sure you did to pop off in
your own city before you had before we
got big energy like because i know it's
a very it's it's a it's a very tough
place to i mean as much as people are
like it's easy everyone in the light is
popping no no it's a lot of competition
it's over saturated because everybody
that live here want to rap and then you
got people who come here to pursue their
rapping dreams or singing dreams or
whatever but i think i really had the
easy way out because i've been doing it
so long like it wasn't no thought
process into this [ __ ] like oh like i'm
an adult now what i'm going to do like
i want to do like i it's all i know like
i've been doing like real when i say
rapping at eight i'm not talking about
like for my mama and [ __ ] i'm talking
about like i would get picked up from
school do my homework in the studio
lobby and then go record type [ __ ] like
full-blown open mics talent shows like
my daddy had me doing everything in
atlanta and that's why like
every artist in london seen me somewhere
like i didn't did a show opened up for
something with every artist in atlanta
so that's why i get so much love and
respect because they like because
they've seen you grow up yeah this ain't
no microwave say no overnight
she put in her [ __ ] work for this
[ __ ] so they respect it do you um
because we always think of like
when you're coming up as an artist right
you have opportunities to open up for
artists sometimes you got to pay to open
up did you ever have to do that
my daddy for sure didn't pay like 200
here three honey here to like just that
just to get you on youtube
do you remember
the first show you opened for
when you were young where you were like
oh [ __ ] i'm opening for this person
[Music]
or somebody random you opened up for
somebody random let me think
there's a lot of random rap concerts it
is but it's gonna be like the [ __ ]
that's more like oh that makes sense
like i didn't open up for future i
didn't open up for gucci way way before
our song
um
like had you told me you opened up for
petey pablo i'd be like hmm how was that
show
and what you're wearing past detroit
fire for travis porter
fire um
shout out to travis porter man i wish
they would have kept
they had a wave what we was just talking
about that in the studio the other day
because um this [ __ ] got me working
with london jay he was like man you need
to make a song um
for the college girls and i was like
[ __ ] travis porter had their ass on
lock hell yeah i need to do that but
yeah shout out travis that's the
legendary atlanta ship but yeah i didn't
open it up for them to every everybody
even one hit wonders out of ellen i
didn't open that for them for sure
there's a lot of one here wonders out of
atlanta it is everybody it's we've been
running it but everybody ain't had the
longevity everyone like there's been
guys who've caught one this one yeah
crazy but it's like where's the
follow-up
and by the way i just want to use this
interview to acknowledge the goat rich
homie quan who i feel like [ __ ] homie
yeah i feel like rich homie quan is like
the mo one of the more under
under-appreciated artists oh yeah for
sure he is his wave i was living in
tampa florida when rachel mcquan was
popping yeah and nobody in the world was
bigger than rachael mcquan for about 20
years
that [ __ ] was on fire i think i
was in like middle school i hope he
catches one soon because that he's very
talented he talented as hell one thing
about it you ain't gonna play with that
man pen y'all know we got a lot of them
like underrated [ __ ] like
rich kids y'all probably don't know
about them but like schooly like we
gotta school is incredible man
talented as hell like talented as hell
like [ __ ] who just never got they
[ __ ] props like people be trying to
play with them like night school's still
going
you know yeah in atlanta i don't give a
[ __ ] a little legend i don't give a [ __ ]
that's facts his pain game's crazy what
that man talented as [ __ ] then he
started all this [ __ ]
but you know this conversation another
day well um
did your dad put you on an outcast when
you were younger hell yeah my daddy
loved [ __ ] um andre that's definitely
gonna be probably
if not his number one top three i'm
gonna say like to me the top five
greatest rapper of all times three
stacks and he's from your city so come
on man what but maybe a bit before your
time you know what i want to say
my daddy was cool with so many people i
could be tripping up like
but
i this how i even started rapping like
my daddy a little street [ __ ] type [ __ ]
so we would be
i'll be running around with him like at
da da house at that house i'm pretty
sure
i've been to big boy house when i was
like a kid i feel like i that sounds
right because i went to atlanta one time
yeah and i ended up at stankonia
and i was like oh my god i'll be
recording i was taking pictures of [ __ ]
i was there listening to kill you know i
met up with killer mike there but i was
like this is [ __ ] legendary
yeah i've been finishing up my well
right now i'm in l.a finishing it but i
was just in atlanta finishing it in um
stank on youtube how was the album
coming along so good so good so good
just trying different [ __ ] right it
really being done i'm not gonna lie but
i'm a capricorn i'm a perfectionist
so you know i put finishing little
tweaks on it yeah and then like i'll be
like waiting for the beyonce feature
yeah you know what i'm saying
wink
wink
no yeah it's coming along real real good
though like do you feel like um
you know
you have like your core fan base that
knows you for like the [ __ ] you've been
doing the last five or six years right
and then you catch this
crossover banger like like big energy is
like it's it it's very much
smash but it's also kind of like a
little different right yeah from what
you're like kind of used to doing it
very different um do you have any like
are you kind of starting to try to lean
into more like doing yeah i'm open put
your toe in some more of the pop [ __ ]
yeah hell yeah cause i want to be [ __ ]
this [ __ ] get me some shmoney some
different money so you know checks got
bigger chase got bigger price went up
price went up price went up so hell yeah
we finna dipple and dab up in that [ __ ]
some mo
i ain't mad at it
so you would just say i'm about 99 done
90 done
i ain't gonna lie to me like if you ask
my a r's i'd be like [ __ ] shut up it's
done but
i think i would say probably like
i say by like 95 because i really just
want to like beat out maybe like two
songs type [ __ ] like if i like these
songs but if i can make like
two songs better than these i'll be
straight let me ask you this you're an
an amazing mc
lyrically you're gifted i mean the super
gremlin freestyle was fire the la
leakers freestyle was special
when it comes to crafting like big hit
records were you ever hesitant about
like maybe having the label bringing
someone to help you with a hook
hell what because you're like what i do
my [ __ ] what
is that even something that's in bounds
like would would you like because oh
yeah because i know you have now you
have like j who i was just talking about
he he a dope ass writer from atlanta
like
but my whole thing is even well start
from the beginning i was like hell [ __ ]
no y'all got me [ __ ] up y'all trying
to turn me into this industry [ __ ] but
then you you know yeah i write my [ __ ]
yeah like you like man hell no but you
mature and you see the bigger picture
you like okay you know what this does
make sense whatever and this is these
people's life you know they they feed
their kids out for this [ __ ] they ain't
finished just off of me
so i start learning like oh everybody do
that that's how y'all need to be
dropping [ __ ] 10 number ones in one
year
oh so i'm like okay i'll do it but it's
never gonna be no situation where you
just bring me some like a song like some
ghost writer ass [ __ ] right we gonna
work together and we collaborate exactly
so where i still have my authenticity to
my song
i'm saying i'm not going to just say
what you tell me to say hell [ __ ] no
yeah i think like a lot of people don't
realize like
when you get to a certain point like
there's a lot of collaborative efforts
in the studio that are very organic it's
not like you said it's not like someone
sends you a song and says yo just record
this no like and i think a lot of times
too when you say writer people think
that's what it is and that's not always
what it is like [ __ ]
i did a session it might be a melody
right yeah i did a session with pharrell
and he's like giving me like i'm in the
booth and he like say this say this like
it don't always mean like
i'm gonna write it and you say it like
it's not always that like abc maybe even
help like with how you say it like yeah
oh god like then i started learning
about what is that called they just tell
me
vocal whatever the hell i don't know
wait wait wait it's a name for that
person
you're in the studio for real
how was that
crazy he don't age was in miami yeah he
[ __ ] don't yeah he [ __ ] don't i do
but he doesn't
shout-outs are for real and he cool as
hell like
i'm like when they told me he wanted to
work with me i'm like [ __ ] are you
talking about pharrell it was like yes
i'm thinking it's it's some new producer
they're calling himself a real some [ __ ]
what a biter
don't they know there's already a
pharrell [ __ ]
but it was [ __ ] for real i'm like why
do you want to work with me
child
what it's like like when because
pharrell is one of the goats right
and we always hear about that i'm so
intimidated yeah
he plays he's going through beats and
you're like i like this one
he like which one you like and you just
like [ __ ] anyone the [ __ ] give me your
throw away i don't give a [ __ ]
i won't make this [ __ ] work to hell
is perrell going to be
anything does he do he have any work on
the project
i think so so pharrell was on the album
i think so yeah i know some people have
been with him recently and he's been
lending some vocals to them is he did he
lend you some vocals on the record
like a little bridge maybe like we did
like five
songs one that i'm choosing um
we still like 95 you know what i'm
saying but
the one that i'm pretty sure i'm gonna
put on there he's not on it
but there was ones that you guys cut
that he was on that's fire
blessed what the hell like that [ __ ]
sound crazy for me to be saying right
now like what yeah
what was there uh can you tell us any
other producers maybe that have made the
cut
um
i know you're not gonna give me any
features so i'm not even gonna ask but
producers maybe
[Music]
let's just say like i i made it a point
to like you know how people be like
focused on the features on the album i
made it a point to be like focused on
the producers on that production i want
you to be like when you read my track
list you like oh the features and then
you read the [ __ ] track list and be
like oh the producers you know what i'm
saying like
not on some like
just do whatever's hot i want you to be
like oh this [ __ ] did her research this
[ __ ] oh she is she from atlanta she
using these [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying you don't you don't see the
thought process in in a production there
is this discussion and i'm asking you
this because obviously for people who
don't know your history you kind of came
up uh you and jermaine depre will always
kind of be related in some aspect right
um always
jd
versus didion of verses
so there was like i can't what you have
no it's never gonna it's never gonna
happen yeah
but wasn't they on live like you know
yes but i was very much in the camp that
jd could upset diddy lowkey i'm not
saying he it would happen i can't even
say nothing about it it would be very uh
i just feel like jeremy some people got
to put some respect on jd's name because
they forget yeah just go listen to
confessions my g oh that's it that's it
that's really like you don't got to say
[ __ ] at the confessions and that yeah
there's so much other you know uh what
may so
obviously you say you signed in uh 2019
end of 2019. yeah what made you finally
make that decision like to sign because
i'm sure everyone was trying to get at
you for a very long time you were
building up and running it up indian in
atlanta what was people don't even be
knowing like i did [ __ ] from the south
independent i did [ __ ] from the south
remix independent i already had put them
shits out independent so it's like i had
everybody at my door i think i just came
to a point where it was like
i feel like i've maxed the independent
route like i feel like my potential is
bigger than this i need a team and
departments in this machine behind me
working 24 7.
yeah for sure someone to brush your hair
before an interview you know
[ __ ] like that
just [ __ ] it's like and then like just
different people working for you and
working with you is like they just
opened your mind to different
stuff like i know i probably wouldn't
have tried big energy two years ago you
know what i'm saying so
just like just people just inspiring you
like and just the roster on the label
like i looked at it as inspiration and
just like
leveling up yo
in the interview got to tell you about
our good folks at odd socks man listen
go to odd socks official dot com use the
promo code 20 off save 20 off some of
the craziest socks you know they got the
ninja turtle joints
uh shout out to kool-aid you know what
i'm saying shots of spongebob plus
they got the odd socks basics
these are my boys right here i love
these right here you get the plain black
the plain white very comfortable most
comfortable socks in the world to be
honest you know what i'm saying plus
underwear y'all cheese it draws
come on what are we doing go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and save 20
off the most comfortable underwear in
the world [ __ ] all that other [ __ ]
y'all be wearing on your ass throw all
the methicas in the trash all that psd
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is all
listen man put the mod socks on your ass
cheeks and thank me later
um
as as crazy as it is right not too long
ago
i feel like
when i was a kid and and when your dad
was obviously me and your dad are
probably
closer in age than you and i um
but you know there was like missy elliot
there was the brat there was little kim
there was like a cool female
foxy brown
but then there was like an era after
that where it was really just nikki
and let's put some respect on trina as
well because trinity's there
i know i know i know um but like it felt
it felt it felt like up until a couple
of years ago that like
for whatever reason hip hop only had
room for one pop and female at the time
oh good and now i feel like we're in the
greatest era of
female artists in hip-hop where it's you
it's may and it's cash doll it's city
girl nikki it's city girls i mean
sweetie we could just keep going down
right cardi b
um
how is it do you feel like it's still
like
like
harder to be a female emcee in today's
climate because i do feel like
there is always like people are going to
judge you harder for whatever reason
yeah it might not be fair but they're
always going to judge you harder
it's hard to talk about that because
it's like yeah it'll always be harder
but you don't want to like take for
granted the progress that we have made
because for sure you know we got it a
lot easier than i'm sure chemin md you
know what i'm saying but yeah i'm
grateful for the progress but it is
still always harder like
when we do these award show performances
and we do it and then [ __ ]
lil whoever young whoever do it the same
stage yeah i ain't picking apart his
performances i ain't telling this [ __ ]
he need to put his lean cup down and run
on the treadmill but y'all gonna be like
she's shopping too much she needs to be
in artist development right like there's
like you could be the biggest rapper in
the world and have a lean gut and be
sloppy as [ __ ] and late to everything
and perform like [ __ ] [ __ ] you
perform like [ __ ] and no one's going to
say anything but nurse
nuts and crosstalk if you're just if
you're a female and you put it together
an amazing performance but like you [ __ ]
up once or
it just feels like every single thing
it's actually under the microscope like
let us do something but [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] all day y'all don't be trying to
cancel their ass or pick a part day
performances and [ __ ] so yeah we do got
it harder but in the same sentence
grateful for where we've come because
you've kind of been on the come up
throughout that whole era yeah so i
didn't yeah for sure like i seen like
it's easy to catch one now like you can
but that's male and female though
it's easy to catch one but yeah tick
tock's got everyone what some of the
[ __ ] on tick tock i'm like what is going
on this kid's getting record deals and
then disappearing oh god what happened
what happened to the board in the house
guy [ __ ] get what little million
dollar deals
never hurt never hear from them a couple
months later but that's that's also
tricky too because you can like
get
excited about [ __ ] like that and chase
that like the tick tock wave and [ __ ]
like that but that [ __ ] not longevity
it's no longer everything there's good
records in real time i feel like a team
would think about who's been around
forever that's the
the cream of the crop is always
around
the the [ __ ] long route think about
like the mount westmore rap it's always
been the last 10 years is kohl's
kendrick and it's drake and all three of
them are murderers on the microphone
mm-hmm
think about
well you know
megan is an amazing emcee i feel like i
think
megan is an acquaintance he will be
playing with megan penn oh she's nice
what yeah she's nice what that [ __ ]
delivery i ain't gonna lie
she wanted him who inspires you
to get better as an mc not defeat not
even just females just in general like
some like maybe someone you've heard
recently we're like damn that
[ __ ] is nice like i gotta get on
my [ __ ]
um
[Music]
[ __ ]
these [ __ ] like we gotta be with you
like you're not gonna have no
turnt up whack ass female rapper like if
if she turned up that [ __ ] is talented
cause we so [ __ ] analyzed dozier
those are killing [ __ ] that [ __ ] can
rap sing pop [ __ ] perform she she her
perfor i feel like her performing is
like i think she's the best performer
i've seen in a long time [ __ ] chloe
what about just armani you don't have to
be females like what have i been anybody
else like
that just is just like inspired japan a
little or like damn like i just heard
this dude go in on this record and i'm
like i need to get my [ __ ] together or
i [ __ ] with rod wave i feel like he made
me want to be on some like authentic
[ __ ] like yeah talk about my life and
[ __ ] like some [ __ ] that people feel
because he his music give me that like
it's it's not going nowhere like this
[ __ ] be there forever yeah like he got
some [ __ ] that i'm gonna play for my
kids and be like hey y'all no nobody
saint pete florida's finest man the 727.
yeah i [ __ ] with rod wave um
i don't know i'll be paying more
attention to the females because that's
my that's my line i get it
you're getting ready for a big tour yeah
which should be fun yeah this will be my
first headline tour first headlining
tour
uh
what's on
lotto's writer
chow pineapples
um jalapeno kettle chips coral water
um
a veggie tray
and i and i had text my manager too and
i told him i needed to update it before
tour too because i need to add
strawberry pop-tarts on there too
strawberry pop-tarts yeah i feel like if
you're eating any other kind of pop-tart
i judge you you ever go to the store
with somebody and they grab the
pop-tarts with no frosting
you're like who [ __ ] who who the [ __ ]
are you what kind of serial killer am i
friends with eating eating no
or really nothing they got them brown
sugar or something like that dumb shits
but it's too though i tried a froot
loops pop-tart 7-eleven i just had to
try it that [ __ ] was terrible ew
i was like yo it could be gas froot
loops i was like i like froot loops
cereal baby no yeah i do like fruit
loose oh and i forgot um hot fries are
hot cheetos
flamin hot fries hell yeah the chester's
flavor not the um the andes thing though
like the blue bag not that there's a hot
cheeto shortage right now so for real oh
yeah
my household can't tell
that pantry stay yeah
you're yo what's crazy is like the hot
cheeto fingers is a thing you'll be
sitting on the couch and then your hands
are just [ __ ] i ain't gonna laugh i'm
at home i'm licking my fingers though of
course you got to yeah
is there anything else with this tour
that you're like are you nervous about
anything like hitting the road and
everyone's there to see you
yeah just cause i feel like you know i
got a top 40 record they like this can't
be no [ __ ] like
too many eyes gonna be on me with this
toy like you know what i'm saying so
it's a little pressure but you know
are you i don't know i'd be praying this
[ __ ] just be working out are you taking
the uh the after-party bags in each of
these hell yeah so we gotta you know
yeah yeah everybody knows i'm gonna come
home with that
go look at the tour dates promoters put
your offers in yeah yeah she'll pull up
yeah i mean it'd probably be a peg for
that bag it's got to be for the bag for
the bag and the cost amigos and the
hookah
ooh the hookah yeah
sprout you know that hookahs
baby pads need a hook uh
[Music]
this [ __ ] ben was on the hookah [ __ ] i
probably wasn't even i was in like
middle school maybe so i wasn't even i
if i was singing this [ __ ] i didn't know
what he was saying anyways what did you
rather just always just let me let me
listen um i never understood the hookah
thing because my thing is if i'm a smoke
i'd rather just get high
no because it's like we don't want to be
paranoid and [ __ ] we ain't trying to be
tripping we just want something to do
when you smoke do you get paranoid
weedy hell yeah who could know you don't
feel no i'm saying when you smoke weed
you get paranoid hell yeah wow i don't
and then i just don't like the action of
smoking like it just like i be confident
y'all how the [ __ ] do y'all do this yeah
i don't like that i think a bug on me
every two seconds i'm jumping like who
the [ __ ] at the door like you might you
might have had angel dust
no every time i hit the blunt i be like
that you know what though i i started
doing like um little like if i'm in l.a
not just like right right um like little
take a little little bite of edible of
the edibles and that [ __ ] helped me
sleep if you do too much
you're gonna have the worst [ __ ] day
of life have you done too much edibles
in ninth grade
oh you was that was some homemade
atlanta [ __ ] then oh what happened wait
because i had the worst day of my life
and i overdosed on an edible so what
happened in ninth grade listen in ninth
grade my friend had this damn lollipop
edible and she just gave it to me
and she didn't tell me like you know
don't eat the whole [ __ ] like it's a
candy like this is drugs same thing oh i
just ate the whole thing and she was
like you ate the whole thing i'm like
[ __ ] you ain't tell me not to the [ __ ]
anyways [ __ ] long story short
i'm tripping i'm going to sleep waking
up like i i'm crying though because i'm
like i don't know if i'm waking up in my
dream or i'm waking up in real life like
tripping so i was like bro i'm finna
google how to come down from a hive
i pull up safari on my phone i had
already googled that [ __ ] yeah i said
yeah no no
also like when you eat it there's
nothing you could do
all you got you got to let it just get
through you nothing
what it was like take a cold shower i
did that i was trying all this [ __ ] did
you hallucinate at all because i i
hallucinated when i was i don't remember
i was tripping the [ __ ] i probably was
though i saw like garfield the cat
he had
he had slot machine eyes so his eyes
were spinning and it'd be dollar signs
see i can't no no
ever since that day i i know
no we're gonna take this little bitty
bite and yeah it'll help you sleep it'll
help you sleep my wife like she'll eat
them to help like she'll like have like
a because it helps you go to bed yes for
sure that [ __ ] helps me sleep because i
i'll use like melatonin or some [ __ ] at
home but when i'm out here i'll be like
oh let me just you ever tried shrooms
[ __ ] no you know busy just did shrooms
for the first time and he was tripping
balls in the snow boosie
booster on the shoes is probably so
funny though oh god it's great
what you think it would be oh yeah
the next time wow next time i interview
boozy i'm like dude show up 30 minutes
earlier we're going to each eat the
shrooms and just see where this takes us
on youtube that [ __ ] wild so [ __ ] so i
can only imagine what he like yeah no
i'm scared of all that stuff though like
i'm telling you like i don't like to be
out of out of my body yeah like i don't
like that like even alcohol like i don't
like to be drunk like i
i'll get a little tipsy you know so i
can feel it when i'm recording [ __ ]
you know what's overrated
in the blue and white bottle you know
what i like that better
i do like it better the most overrated
yo that [ __ ] is overrated and i'll be
rapping about that [ __ ] too
but
i take they were both no hell yeah and
it's like 45 dollars i like it better
than all of this what is the
the cheap [ __ ] yeah yes me too when i go
to the club and they're like whatever
bottle you want i'm either they're like
bro why don't you get it
i'm like
who doesn't taste it's okay it's like
it's more about like hey look every time
i've gotten drunk like throw up drunk is
off of yes
like rich people's patronus
it's like not great
i'm so straight on that [ __ ] give me the
cheap [ __ ] like not too cheap nah don
julio blanco and casa amigos is fire
i i ain't gonna lie because i was on
for a minute and then i was like getting
burnt on that and i'm getting back on
the um go now did you did you know uh
george clooney owns cos amigos
the actor
what he's the owner
she making george clooney richard down
to him
hey man
[Music]
have you had any opportunities to
endorse any products or have your own
like something like that because i'm
sure you've had hell opera hey lotto let
us give you your own weed strain or hey
let us let's you want to you want your
own vodka or maybe trying to do like the
weed strand [ __ ] i just be like it's too
fake cause i talk about how i don't
smoke all day right it was like that's
that's too fake i would do like an
alcohol or something like that i didn't
do like swimwear clothing collabs like
she like did you ever do the fashion
nova deal
no i'm a pretty little thing yeah pretty
little thing pretty little thing baby
they cut the check so pretty little
thing is uh
a very big company yeah they got it they
got their own uh thing over on melrose i
mean they're doing their thing pretty
little thing is doing the thing so
you're pretty did you have your own
collection with them yet
we supposed to be doing that
i gotta finish this deal if they don't
give you you a pretty little thing
collection in the next six months you
better jump on over to fashion nova
because they're gonna
they're gonna give you those don't get
me [ __ ] up they're going to give you
the whole [ __ ] thing they're going to
be like lotto spring collection oh and
stuff with jack smithy mm-hmm wait you
wait wait wait what savage expensive
riri um you got you got the fancy
popping yes
we really lingerie and i ain't gonna lie
no that [ __ ] and like no cap like off
the record like this ain't even know
like paid promo she like no that [ __ ]
fire defense the quality [ __ ] fire the
designs and [ __ ] i'm like is she doing
this [ __ ] i don't know whoever doing it
they should be fire like have you ever
talked to really honestly
but
i think she replied live you playing my
song before what song [ __ ] from the
south
i was like river you a [ __ ] from the
south girl she's from barbados i feel
like she'd reply to the dm
if i dm'd her i'd be so weird like i
don't like like making people feel
pressured yeah you know like
i don't know i'm weird like that
do you ever like we'll be backstage not
to cut you off my bed yeah we'll be
backstage and they'd be like oh da da
back here go say hey to daraan i'd be
like no no they come say hi to me or i'm
gonna run into them if i run into them
it's organic what happened like i don't
like to like do the whole like
i don't know that just make people feel
weird because i know like i don't want
people doing that to me i respect that
how often do you check your dms oh i
don't check my demons your dm's got to
be a dark place
[Music]
yeah i don't check my dm's i got a man
and i don't even mean like in i mean
obviously
random dick pics i'm sure are coming are
you flying through those just too weird
because it'll be like from
eight-year-old boys and [ __ ] and it's
like y'all making me uncomfortable
that's [ __ ] up can you imagine not
knowing what you're opening and then
it's an eight-year-old dick like
like y'all make me just want to delete
the whole app i would yeah i'm off
social media though i don't check them
yo it's like when i went on twitter once
and i saw tiger's dick on accident
i was like bro i did not sign up to see
tiger's dick
social media in general is just a lot of
times i had to like check out
and like just do something normal
because gotta get consumed in this like
virtual reality
[ __ ] is it um
nice to be in a relationship when you're
going through the the stuff you're going
through in your career so you kind of
have like a safe place yes oh my god oh
my god like that's my [ __ ] safe zone
that's my sanity for real life that's
when i can come home
from the studio crying and just
overwhelmed with everything and i just
saw eight-year-old dick help me
hold me
um
that's dope no because i mean i'm
married and it's the same thing i think
like a strong relationship is very
important like it's you know if it's a
strong relationship if it's toxic it
could also get you [ __ ] up right
because that [ __ ] can just be too much
like i didn't been in a toxic
relationship where it just does nothing
for you now this is that [ __ ] like this
the one so i know
what it feels like to have that like
safe space you and your man what shows
do you binge watch at home snowfall we
binge watched
snowfall we was late to the
parties yeah don't play with franklin
hey season five is coming yes we was
just talking about that car it's five
because i think we binge watched one
through four yeah so [ __ ] good
let me ask you this is a serious
question yeah
you and i have both watched the show
so good
watching the show
did you think even for a split second
i'd like to try crack because it looks
fire no i did not [ __ ] think that
no not when you see um no i said when i
saw franklin saints girlfriend smoke
crack
she looked like she was like having the
time of her life in one episode franklin
saint's girlfriend flushed her whole
[ __ ] life down the toilet that's what
i'm saying
and um wanda the other girl yeah she's
[ __ ] up throughout almost this but
frank went freaking that [ __ ] don't look
funny when the cop's daughter
hit the crack pipe yeah and it hurt
it was one episode long and her whole
[ __ ] hey i ain't gonna lie i'm ready for
that [ __ ] to come back cause you
bringing back memories i forgot about
her daddy being a cop yeah i was like
damn the cops daughter smoke crack once
and just it was over i'm like that [ __ ]
gotta be crazy
no
no
i'm not saying i'm considering it i'm
saying for a split second i thought to
myself crack's got to be fired let's be
honest like i mean i'm not saying i'm
going to do it i get your you know you
see what i'm saying you saying like if
if you know what he's going to do to you
and you like you will you ready if
you're willing to like sell
your car and your jewelry your grandma
gave you is dead
and disappoints your police thank you
your policeman father yeah you know it
it what is it yeah
yeah it's crazy well look that's how
we're gonna end the interview on crack
no wait wait no we cannot no talk about
something else first listen uh the song
is out and it's going crazy
[Music]
the album is coming soon yeah pretty
soon
really soon like really soon like when i
say 95. i'm gonna be bumping your [ __ ]
by
a march madness maybe you know a little
top top
i'm just saying yeah yeah i can't think
i'm going to go on tour without dropping
the album
when's the tour start
march 19th
so there's going to be an album before
march 19th ladies and gentlemen
dozier cat's going to be on the big
energy remix
and
and
hopefully we get beyonce on there too
hey baby we're going to shoot for the
stars
we got to put it out there beyonce on
the [ __ ] that man beyonce's going to put
you on her album oh [ __ ] what it just
got [ __ ] deep in this [ __ ]
say what
uh the tour starts march 19th yeah
any new freestyles or anything coming
yeah the super gremlin one was nice and
you were early on that too because now
it's like the biggest [ __ ] record you
know what how early i was cause i was
telling my anr's i was like i need to
drop a freestyle before the end of the
year just to like hope or whatever and i
was like i was stuck between the super
gremlin and this other song and i was
like should i just do this song because
the super grilling i don't even know if
people don't know like i don't want them
to think this is my song right type [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying because it was
still like bubbling and it was like nah
by the time you drop it you're going to
be ahead of like they literally called
everything that's happening right now
like it was like you're going to drop it
you're going to be ahead of it and it's
going to blow up right at the same time
it's going to be perfect uh kodak reach
out be like yo good job or thank you for
yeah we got a song together he was just
like you know what honey like he's a
very interesting guy yeah he crazy he's
an enigma he crazy you know yeah he
crazy i feel like he's like
yeah he's kodak black he's one of one
yeah he's crazy yeah shout out to kodak
something that flow to water it's in
that floor i'd live there trust me
florida's a wild place it is you know
what i love first 48 and it seemed like
that [ __ ] always in florida
it also seems like everything that ever
happens that's embarrassing is in
florida yes
like wendy's employee
reverse drive-by shoots their boss while
getting a frosty and then crashes into a
mcdonald's across the street while
cooking meth in their back seat in
florida saint petersburg florida you got
to let them float pinellas county
sheriff reports
what yo you've gotten a lot of bags in
florida right yeah i know i love florida
especially i mean it's going to sound
like very touristy but especially miami
like yeah miami's in the city yeah what
i love miami what's been the
because florida's like its own country
so like depending on what part of
florida you go to oh yeah there's like
miami and then there's like
teethless redneck like crazy florida and
then there's like
the hoods in florida are different
because they're like country
so you might go to like palmetto florida
and it's it's wild yeah florida's wild
planet and i'm sure you've been up in
you've gotten bags in a lot of those
cities
oh yeah i didn't did a lot of florida
clubs i didn't did the [ __ ] what's
that ratchet ass strip club in miami um
which one g5 i did g5 before
it's another one booby trap
the office oh the office yeah the office
is oh geez
and it's small in there smallest hills
office is tiny dangerous as hell they
was definitely violating a lot of codes
in there so fun though oh yeah the
office is a vibe i appreciate you
pulling up lotto
the tour and the album come in march
19th yeah we're going
to tour or not do you have the name of
the album
i have it but we don't the world don't
have it yet soon enough is the artwork
already shot the cover's already i mean
no but i was when i was in the car here
i'm looking at the treatments oh
all right well there it is i'm sure
follow-up single coming
of course all right of course be on the
lookout sooner than soon sooner than
soon lotto yeah there it is the biggest